I I want to get Oliver tree weigh in
thoughts question what's going on well a
lot of things come to mind for one in
your research since you are such a
public figure since you are so outgoing
in the public speaking about this on the
news have you had people from the
government reach out to you about these
phenomenons at all is this something
that you feel like your life is ever in
danger not because of necessarily fans
but because of some of the information
that you're bringing to light in the
more mass eyes are you posing a threat
am I that's National Security not but do
you feel like ever that it's you feel
maybe that there is some Danger from
this yeah uh so back to what you said
real quick which is that the term people
are using is non-human intelligence
because the word alien like anything
unknown to us is alien you know so they
call him non-human intelligence we just
had a thing in Congress when that was a
good way um to your question you know
have I ever been contacted dude of
course I mean I'm obtaining and
releasing military filmed footage that
are of bonafide UAP through leaks that
comes to me they have to do
investigations they have to plug leaks
that's an important job when it comes to
you know proper Transit of
information uh my relationship has
always been really great in that no one
as a journ jist you know has ever uh
tried to stop the the freedom of press
in that way freedom of speech and also
for public good as a journalist there's
a little bit of a something called
Shield law and there's other laws that
say look if you're reporting something
for public good and you obtain you can
obtain anything just don't [__] up you
know Do no harm National Security with
UFOs is a real deal the UFO topic is
considered by our government at a level
higher than weapons of mass destruction
that's not a throwaway statement that
that is fact I know that to be true so
here's the deal Do no harm I I am a
patriot and but you know I'm also a
little bit of a pirate and you've seen
that by when I obtain and release stuff
but I always try to do so with knowledge
that it's been done wrong before and it
is not my intent to harm National
Security it is not and I think anybody's
ever engaged me from any Agency on that
you know they clearly see I'm not some
like crazy pirate you know I'm just
interested in this so just to finish
your qu question
directly I've always been you know I've
never been resisted I can say that I
I've been assisted but the the scary
thing to me is that journalists get
better briefings more footage better
understanding of some of these UFO cases
than our government uh Representatives
do so I've not been the subject where
I've been briefed oftentimes I have
briefed on specific things which is
[__] frightening
that there's so much of a problem of the
transmission of this information where
it should go because again that's the
qualification thing I'm just a report a
journalist that's looking at this that
there's got to be people that have a
better grasp on this within our
government but who contacts you like the
Men in Black show up no how's that [__]
work and like exchanging emails with
this sensitive information like is it
encrypted like is there protocols you
have to do oh yeah yeah as a journalist
I'm getting and obtaining information I
I just have like a couple catchalls so
when people kind of get through to a
certain point everybody knows those
catchalls exist completely encrypted
everything is is totally to the highest
degree in quality but I don't always
know what's going to come in people
could send [__] anything which is
also kind of frightening too right so
from the journalism side as a journalist
I don't want to know who gave me what I
want to corroborate it so as long as
there's enough information that comes
along with whatever sent I can
corroborate it I never want to know
specific specifically who gave me
anything um the other part of that is
how do people contact you so this is a
weird world that I'm living in where I'm
actually dealing with stuff where the
Pentagon doesn't have some of the
footage from their fleets that I was
able to obtain so that's an
uncomfortable conversation I'm about to
go public with something right and I did
and then I gave it with George nap as
journalist we gave this information to
the Pentagon they're like we didn't have
this so that's an awkward conversation
then of course it has to be an inv
instigation of how that stuff got out I
get that that's the footage from the USS
was it Omaha there have been a few
instances but the USS Omaha USS Russell
10 of our Navy warships were swarmed by
UFOs or UAP unknowns I call them units
and they seem to appear to be trans
medium go in and out of the water with
total impunity and a lot of times these
things are are fired upon I'll say not
necessarily with like metal bullets but
sometimes with electromagnetic Weaponry
on the ships electromagnetic weaponry
that we have that we have yeah yeah so
like if you have like anti- drone
technology if you're on one of these
warships you got something called the
Ghostbuster they literally say bust out
the Ghostbuster and it's this backpack
and it can shoot down a lot of the
common drones there's higher levels of
electromagnetic Weaponry to take down
systems of objects approaching or um if
there's an incursion in your
space I know of three that were
attempted on multiple swarm incidents
but I feel like we jump around so just
reel it back into one point no I sorry I
just brought that up because that's
stuff that you gave to the Pentagon that
they didn't have some of that footage
absolutely they didn't have other parts
of that footage were in um what at that
time was a classified document that was
shown to educate the the armed services
about UFOs um there was a couple images
from that which I obtained but there was
other like the radar data stuff like
that all from the same event like
corroborative Visual Evidence you got
radar thermal infrar read deck footage
normal camera footage all showing the
same event Series so it's one of the
most well documented now confirmed UAP
or UFO events in military history
because I was able to get all of that
footage and bring it together but right
back to your original question just want
to finish one thing tie it up um look
within the numerous intelligence
agencies within the US there's a high
interest in this UFO thing it's not
nefarious necessarily it's seeking
quality and actionable information it
would make sense that people would try
to gather that and go talk to people
both overtly and covertly so I've had
both I I've experienced both where I had
to find out later the true agenda people
that inserted themselves into my lives
but then overtly just hey you're not in
trouble nothing's wrong I'm from ex
agency just want to talk to you if you
call me back about this I'm not trying
to find out sources or methods or [__]
up your thing in any way just want to
get a little information if that's okay
and all of that has happened do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
sto's butt wipes for your butthole are
available on Amazon and if you want a
real bundle of a deal you can get sto's
hot sauce fre your butthole plus sto's
butthole destroyer and sto's butt wipes
for your but but hole it's the butthole
bundle available on Amazon right
now yeah dude